why that is is because they are unable
to have stable families because they no
longer believe in hierarchies they don't
no longer believe that a man should be
the man of the house and they should
have the final say on a general capacity
as a result of that what we're seeing is
the disintegration of family stabilizing
of such families and we're seeing
divorce
today we are going to talk about the
muhammadi job
and the Jordan Peterson part two
and if y'all were giving Jordan Peterson
some heat because of the whole Ben
Shapiro Al-Aqsa thing just know that
this recording was actually before that
yeah so this is um this is before the
timelines a little weird but just just
so you know just so you know so without
further Ado let's get right into it
I said that you know from from a Muslim
perspective the question that we're
asked to ask is bring the evidence yeah
if I were to bring reasonable evidence
which would satisfy some kind of
probabilistic reasoning that the prophet
Muhammad we believe is the final Prophet
right that he was a true Prophet would
you be willing to become a Muslim bro he
literally just asked them Point Blank
man
and that's bro there's some people
that's how it has to be done bro
honestly okay and with him I think it's
about time I know bro Andrew Tate on bro
I'm just gonna be like bro are you ready
I wouldn't
um
I wouldn't
dispute a priority the idea that
Muhammad was a true prophet
but I don't understand what that means
it's like obviously so this is the way
I'm going to look at this
psychologically again you know it's
people are granted Revelations and it's
obviously the case let's speak
empirically that the revelation of
Muhammad United a fractious society and
so it was a uniting revelation now how
to conceptualize but it's not a
universally uniting Revelation at least
not yet or not now because we're not all
United so
why maybe we didn't understand the
Revelation point is the presupposition
what you're saying that Unity is the
ultimate objective well not exactly you
know because then you have the problem
of uniformity that you know even the
idea of unity itself I mean we talked
about okay just to be clear yeah I
believe that Unity is a great objective
yeah but I don't think it's the old
defining one for example
um if there's a if there is an injustice
that is so great that this Unity is more
appropriate than I can imagine
situations where disunity is probably
better than Unity right I'm sure you can
so for example that would be a false
Unity yes exactly so well that's why you
wanted to address the elephant
and we can't incorporate things we can't
yet incorporate yes the reason why I'm
bringing this to your attention is
because I feel like it's my two years of
Muslim especially in the Moscow to to
tell you that
um as Muslims we believe that the
previous dispensations as they were like
Christianity and Judaism they are part
of our faith in a sense not in the sense
of believing the doctrines and all that
kind of thing like we obviously don't
believe in original sin or the
Resurrection the crucifixion all these
kind of things we don't believe any of
that or the Trinity of course
um but in the sense that we do believe
in Jesus Christ we believe in all of the
Old Testament prophets most of them if
not all of them you know Abraham Moses
Jesus and so on and we believe that each
Prophet was sent with two things the
message which is to believe in
worshiping one God and some kind of
evidence to indicate their truthfulness
so with for example Moses and Jesus we
know what their miracles are playing the
scene and we believe that actually
happened historically right we have no
qualms with that we don't have this kind
of materialistic viewpoint on the issue
with Muhammad we believe that his
because he was sent to All of humanity
he had to have a an Evidence base that
would satisfy not just the eyes in other
words it wouldn't be just something that
could be witnessed it would be something
that can be interrogated and scrutinized
for all times and places so it would be
an auditory of Revelation in this case
it's the Quran the Quran means a
recitation yeah so the central message
of the Quran is or the idea of
worshiping one God and believing in one
God as we mentioned
but there are some there is an attempt
in the Quran to challenge like for
example there's something called the
falsification test or the inevitability
test the Quran says for example that try
and find a contradiction within the
Quran had it been from other than God
founded in many contradictions it's this
invisibility challenge is to produce
something as sophisticated as it in
terms of the linguistic composition as
well as the structural component
um this is very interesting because now
even Western academics like Angelica
neuros and others have said that this
man this challenge has not been met it's
a German orientalist she's recently said
this
um so this is another thing and then you
have a range of prophecies for example
like if you look at the Deuteronomy
chapter 18 verse 21 it's mentioned in
the Bible that one of the mark Hallmarks
of a true Prophet is that or a false
prophet is that when they talk about the
future that it will be false but the
Quran makes very specific very specific
prophecies about the future for example
in chapter 3 verse two to four it says
that the Romans had been defeated at
that time there was assassinated Empire
in the Roman Empire and they were in a
war with each other and that from three
to nine years that they would defeat the
enemy you see it gave very specific time
timelines it gave very specific and this
was a very risky type of prediction
because if you got it wrong then it
would endanger and undermine the entire
prophet of the Prophet Muhammad well it
did happen in fact you'll find
Historical things which I'm not even in
the Quran Rome was defeated that wrote
no the the Persians sorry that the
Romans had been defeated by the Persians
in a battle Yeah uh and so that's it's
mentioned for example The Chronicles of
theophanes which is a primary source
material outside of the Quran
um you can find it now it's even
translated into English he clearly
mentions that eight years after this
particular prediction took place it did
happen like that so we have a range of
predictions even that relate to the
current day the prophet said that the
the barefoot in Arab because there will
be competing for the highest building
that's actually transmitted diseases
would be proliferated as a result of
people having intercourse outside of
marriage and that this would be
something that would be diseases that
had never been there in the past uh the
interest rate interest based economy
that we live in is mentioned by The
Proposal in the future interests will be
everywhere
consumer he will not be able to evade
his dust
so this other thing so for example
you've got a range of prophecies where
Islam will spread country by country
where you know this mentions he's going
to go uh
that the Earth has been expanded for me
West points and East points
and my nation will reach
its points what was projected and it's
in east and west if you look at the
Islamic expansion I mean Barbie Rogerson
yeah who is a historian he said that the
similitude of the Muslims going Eastward
and Westward and conquering the amount
of countries that they conquered in that
early period which we can read in the
book I've given you it's like Eskimos
taken over Russia and America
on the point of prophecies even people
like Edward Gibbons they agree that the
Prophecies of the Quran had been met so
so I have to ask yeah so I don't I don't
I don't understand the question exactly
he wants to know if you convert to Islam
no I'm saying that no that wasn't me
oh look I would say to somebody it's not
up to me but my question was just around
you the question was if I gave you
evidence that would satisfy a certain
level of probabilistic no
no because that isn't how I evaluate the
situation how would you evaluate that
I mean this very specifically you know
um I don't think in some sense
it's a very complicated problem okay
you know when people meet me on the
street they'll say things like I met a
couple of Orthodox Jews in New York and
they said to me on the street that they
called me Rabbi which was
it's a hell of a thing to hear
let me kind of push back a little bit on
that point because you're an individual
like obviously in your newest book
you're talking about
um categorically about precision and I
would say you're an individual that is
very precise they're categorized like if
I was say anything I would say that
you're individual that's grouplessly
meticulous an executed and I don't know
meticulousness or whatever yeah so you
speak and you think about what you're
going to say before you say it that's
what you're known for in fact if someone
says something which is uh kind of off
the market here but you pull them up for
it right and you're usually because I
don't understand it then yeah for
example like the Kathy Newman interview
like the assumptions and the questioning
that she had she had when she was
questioning yourself you pulled her up
on it and that's why it became so uh
popular the discussion was so popular
and you're a clinical psychologist so
what's going to say is that for example
if I were to make a video right I'll
send this message to you know to White
Canadians or something yeah and I said
you know it's hard to talk to them and
say look you know um sensitively why
don't you reach out to some Russians you
know or you know heaven forbid you know
reach out to like Africans or First
Nation people you know whatever it may
be how do you think
the community of white Canadians let's
say for sake of argument will react to
that kind of tomorrow where did homes
resources go
no bro I was gonna say
like when we first me and on hell I was
gonna say when we both saw him sources
appear where we were both like what the
heck where did he come from yeah
we heard so far yeah I'll let this clip
finish there's just a few seconds left
well if it was you yeah well you're
pretty disagreeable so you'd probably
get bit back a lot yeah but exactly I
don't I don't it's hard to say until you
do one you know yeah I mean I have
reached out to other communities let's
say I did an interview with a friend of
mine who's a Native American Carver who
lives on the west coast and you know I'm
not very happy with the
um okay that was it
subhanallah one thing I want to get off
my chest because I feel like oh man part
of me feels like my heart's about to
break
because I feel like and I'm not talking
about muhammadabs in particular or
anyone in particular I'm just saying
that generally and I haven't seen
anything other than what we just watched
this is my first time seeing anything of
Jordan Peterson and Mom and a job too
but one thing that stands out to me
tremendously and I think Jordan Peterson
proved it like unequivocally proved it
is he doesn't need arguments he doesn't
need intellectual demonstrations of why
Islam is this man needs to be
emotionally convinced bro he needs to be
that he's such an emotional God Allah
may Allah bless him and got him to Islam
he's talking about a group of Jews I
came and called him Rabbi bro he luckily
he was about to cry man he needs to be
right not just rationally but he needs
to be emotionally convinced that Islam
is the truth and we can do that bro it's
Wallah it's easy
you know if if
I'll give you a few examples first and
foremost you find a pain point in his
life you find something that's crunching
him in his life that's hurting him in
his life and you show him in the Quran
and the son of the Prophet salaam
exactly a word that's dealt with and
exactly how and exactly what there was a
clip of Hamza from hamza's Den a
Speaker's Corner with an older white guy
all right and I'm not just saying that
because Jordan Peterson's an older white
guy but that's who he was talking to and
and he he noticed from this man you know
his older guy probably his grandkids and
he's like listen you're gonna love this
and he told them about the Hadith of the
prophetam
um
basically
uh where he talks about I think
fulfilling your obligation towards your
parents
and the old man looked like he was about
to cry because you could tell maybe his
kids don't visit him as often as he
wants him to
you know that's what makes Islam stand
out to people or play something from the
Quran with with the recitation
uh that is melodious as Allah instructed
us to and and and takes its time
reciting the Quran with the translation
so that he you know on something that's
really related to him and his life
something that he needs to hear because
Allah we have as we have basically
circumstances for revelation
all right why the Quran was revealed at
particular times and what they were in
regards to so find one other not me you
know I'm not scholar I'm not I'm not a
muhamed I don't know the the Hadith very
well one things were revealed but find
something that will fit him in his life
insha Allah and give it to him and just
cater to his emotions inshaallah what do
you think
I think that's beautiful man I was just
thinking about how like
this is why the Quran and Islam in total
is just so beautiful because our logic
sometimes is kind of like this barrier
before we get to our emotions like
people who are logical they're going to
be logical before they're emotional so
there's a barrier you have to go to the
logic before you get to the emotions and
it's crazy because it's lamb and the
Quran like it not only does it speak to
the emotions but it speaks to the logic
and then once it it brings down the
barrier of the wall or the logic like it
hits the emotions like nothing else
and like that that's exactly what Jordan
Peterson means well 100 and I want to
comment on that I know I'm sorry I
jumped off right at the bat and I
started talking so much and I'm still
talking a lot but this is just something
I'm very passionate about so forgive me
guys but I want to mention two things
before I pass it on to five so and what
you said is correct and essentially when
we and I want to privilege with Jordan
Peterson we make up our minds
before we actually realized we logically
made up our mind
like if if someone were to ask you
something emotionally you would have an
answer you would decide how you
emotionally feel about it before you
decide what's logically correct
and you realize you notice that if you
go back to clip watch with Jordan
Peterson he said no just like Muhammad
said you like to sit and think about
your answer he said no and then thought
about his answer he's if as a
psychologist he should know this himself
or as a psychologist I'm not an expert
obviously so if he wants to repeat me on
the inshallah go ahead but you know he
should know this himself and he should
recognize it in that clip and he should
know that no amount of logical
convincing will actually convince him
because what he has is is an emotional
kind of problem with it and from a I'm
taking again I'm not an expert by any
means it's one elective in school but
I'm taking a culture and media of course
and they talk about how the media is the
message and that the way you distribute
the message is basically the message in
and of itself and I was looking at the
Quran
from that perspective and the Quran is
so tremendous in delivering the message
because not only is it clear logical
rational and concise but it's recited in
a melodious way which is it already
impacts your heart so much more because
it involves your emotions so it's
emotionally convincing you it's
logically and rationally convincing you
and on top of that Allah is telling us
stories which is something Jordan
Peterson does a lot in his lectures when
he was a professor at University
specifically because he knows that's a
great way to communicate so from a
culture and media perspective the Quran
is phenomenal and honestly I will say
this firmly
on top of everything and anything else
in the world right now any movie
any any any film any song anything in
the world the Quran delivers this
message better than it I will say that
foreign what do you think bro what were
your thoughts
I think it's a shame bro that a lot of
these educational institutions and a lot
of these you know platforms they focus a
lot and maybe even you know we ourselves
were prone to this in the beginning you
know we spent a little bit of an over
emphasis on the logical proofs of Islam
which is not a bad thing by the way
because there is a time and a place for
that but just like brother Holmes Resort
has said on the podcast that we had with
him that some people they just need you
to like just take them out for like a
slice of pizza you know and just chop it
up just talk about random things in life
and and just see them as a person bro as
a human not as someone that you need to
like intellectually debate and try to
refute and you know what I mean because
if something can do that but that like
most people don't need that bro most
people need soul food
you know thanks 100 100 you know a heart
a heart that is sincerely reminded of
Allah and and and opens up to that again
wool year and for Allah that is
something we know about the human being
even like subhanallah like remember in
the state of the Prophet when he was
resetting Surah and for anyone who
doesn't know Surah is is so powerful
it's so powerful I didn't know it was I
first heard it recited by mensured
salimi but subhanallah like it impacted
me and and then I I correlated it with
this Hadith which says the process Adam
he was reciting Surah najam to his
people
and by the end of it he said basically
you know prostrate to your lord and
worship him
and
everyone even the non-muslims frustrated
because they believed in a lot everyone
prostrated and there was only one
arrogant guy who didn't prostrate
but at the very least he took the dirt
from the ground and put it up to his
forehead you know it's like even he
realized you know that this is the truth
and he was so overcome with the emotion
instead of falling to the ground he he's
like I need to grab this dirt and put it
on my head because I can't even though
I'm air too arrogant to put myself down
I need to bring it up here
I don't know
that's the impact it has subhanallah
sheesh man may Allah allow us to
overcome our emotional blocks bro I mean
I mean bro that's being promoted in
Canada which is that the European
settlement of Canada is best viewed as
genocidally Colonial and having said
that my friend this Carver was in a
residential school in Canada and the
residential schools were put forward by
the government in an attempt and other
institutions an attempt to separate the
indigenous children from their families
and then socialize them rapidly
according to European norms and there
was some positive motivation for that
and sometimes that helped and worked but
it wasn't the things that did happen was
that some schools were let's say invaded
by people of a pronounced pedophilic and
and sadistic bent and my friend ended up
in one of those schools and his life was
so Dreadful that you can't even hear
about it without without
without serious emotional damage and so
you know I went forward without
discussion and it was very contentious
but it went very well and it it told a
story that was true and needed to be
told and so you know you step into
foreign territory at your peril that's
for sure but you know and it was
relatively difficult for me to arrange
for this to be a possibility and and but
my my thought again because I'm trying
to look for what we have to offer each
other rather than what divides us I
thought it was worthwhile push back
again once again on this planet so for
example it's not always what you say
sometimes it can be what you don't say
so for instance
I think you've become somewhat of an
emblem of Western Civilization right in
terms of your intention help us no you
have and I'll also push back a point
this is a foreign culture because I
think that Islam I mean you've mentioned
this in lectures all that Islam has now
become part of like you know Western
culture yeah well that's the open
question as as we noted in the
introductory marks it's like well our is
Islam part of the West we're kind of
having the same discussion about Russia
in some real sense yeah that's really
going well at the moment yeah so there's
that part but what I would say is that
you know if there is a bloody history of
Western colonialism and that's almost
undeniable like for example look at
Algeria for instance Algeria when it was
annexed by France and there's no
disputed there's no dispute in what
happened there so like I'll give you one
example of many the Spanish colonialism
of Latin America for example
um there are things that happened and
it's also things that happened on only
just on the Western Front yeah uh those
things happened of course this is true
yeah no doubt about it right no I'm not
going to stand here and you know defend
them who came and we're very intolerant
to uh Jews and Christians and kicked
them out of their homes and stuff like
that who because they're in Spain as
well in fact so the point is I feel like
I don't know as a psychologist I think
my question would be to you don't you
think is it of any benefit to be
concessionary in this regard like to
start off a discussion by saying like we
know
um that these are things that could
cause resentment yes because like for
example I know a lot of Algerian people
and this is very clear in their
historical memory yes and the the
accusation will be that the West have
Colonial Amnesia here they don't they
are not taking into account what they've
done I'll be honest with you they don't
even know how well okay yeah well
absolutely I mean look here here's how I
would address that psychologically
um in in many of the mythological
stories that I've read There is the
motif of the evil uncle
and so for example in ancient Egyptian
cosmology
um that there were two there were four
deities four essential deities although
a host of associated deities and one of
them was Osiris who was the deity of the
state that might be a good way of
thinking about it and he had an evil
brother Seth who was always conspiring
in the background to overthrow the state
and to establish his own rules say based
on Power and the Egyptians this is
thousands of years ago had figured out
by that point because their society was
quite large that
there was something in the social
structure itself that posed a threat to
the structure and that was the tendency
for the structure and its leaders to
become willfully blind and for
conspiratorial
powers or patterns that would use
resentment and the desire for power to
overthrow that and they thought of
Osiris as willfully blind and Seth has
an eternal danger and that's true and
and then but there's a there's another
element to the evil Uncle too which is
that in some real sense and it's a very
difficult thing to sort through morally
all of us walk on blood soaked ground
because human history is in some regards
a nightmarish catastrophe and some of
that's just because life was so
difficult but it's also because people
did in unbelievably cruel and malicious
and deceptive uh committed committed
unbelievably cruel and atrocious and
deceptive acts and so we're all stuck
with this problem that
here we are in relative peace and
Harmony so far although we seem to be
doing everything we can to try to
disrupt that at the moment and part of
the price that's being paid for that is
an endless Litany of historical
catastrophe and then we all have to face
up to well what does that mean for us in
terms of our individual responsibility
and how do we construe ourselves and our
society in light of that fact and we
could go back and forth continually
about whose historical atrocities were
worse and that's a rough contest because
you know the devil is definitely in the
details there and then it also brings up
the other problem which is well
when the Spaniards went to Central
America a lot of the Bloodshed they
produced the death they produced was
actually a consequence of the
introduction of disease because that
took out about 95 percent of the native
population in the Western Hemisphere and
then the conquistadors were well maybe
they weren't the finest representatives
of the of the highest flowering of
Western Civilization we don't know what
to what degree they were the sort of
thugs that couldn't get along at home
and went out adventuring and and then
and and even if I say attempted to take
full responsibility for that I'm not
sure what it would mean because I
suspect I have a lot more in common with
you people in the modern world than I do
with Spanish conquistadors from 300
years ago now I'm not saying I bear no
responsibility for the Bloodshed of the
past but I would say we all bear that
responsibility and that's something I
would say that's something like the
conception of original sin yeah that's
the point of difference to be honest I
would disagree with that point like as a
Muslim there's a versatile says
that one Soul should not bear the
responsibility of someone else's actions
yeah well that that's the other ethical
complex
because at the same time you do say and
I don't mean you personally but you know
we can say things like Well the West is
not bearing sufficient responsibility
for its Colonial past and so at some
level that kind of devolves down to the
individual so let me let me kind of
rephrase it then I think I think that's
more of a left and criticism it's like
you know it's reparations and
affirmative action programs yeah I'm not
advocating any of that and no I even
believe in any of that to be honest with
you nor me yeah so what I was putting as
an alternative to that is this is there
is this kind of I would call this maybe
an oriented it's a new orientalist
narrative which states that Islam is
incapable of XYZ call it tolerance
whatever it is and look at what's
happened in Islamic history you've got
all of these deaths and you've got all
of these kinds of things are happening
comparative to what we have in the west
and what we're saying is that let's look
at what you have in the west because
liberalism was an ideology that was
signed in the 17th century like I mean
really it was crystallized you know with
John Locke and all those kind of things
then and after liberalism was
established in fact the constitution in
fact the documents of founding files and
stuff like that were based on the
liberal secular principles even after
that you had Napoleonic Wars even after
that you had colonialism because then
you had slavery continue until 1867
whenever it was you know the American
Civil War ended
um so what we're saying is that this
picture of history that you know the
West is best basically this idea because
our ideology can fix all problems it's
not reasonable when you look at
historical records I mean one of um
one's called actually done a piece it's
called body count and he was counting
the amount of people that died in each
civilization and he put the Western
Civilization is the highest and because
you have to think that World War One of
World War II these things were World War
One World War II were nationalistic
conquests they were not religiously
inspired well you cannot you can argue
to what extent world one was religiously
inspired but certainly Islam didn't was
not a main feature of the 30 million
people that died in World War One or
however many many people done so the
point is that we're saying is that and
obviously you've got Concepts in the
west like Manifest Destiny and which I
think every single president of the
United States of America believed in
Westwood expansion these kind of things
the point is is that it's a proposition
that the ideology of the West can fix
our problems this is what we have an
issue with because what was saying is if
we look at the historical record there
is no evidence of that in fact what has
shown us is that there's more Bloodshed
individualism has caused More Death like
of all due respect I know they said that
you you do cherish individuals I'm not
saying everything is bad about it when
you have a society deplete of a
communitarian ethic
is bereft of a communitarian ethic then
you can have these issues and so these
are conversations and I think you are
moving towards a communitarianism your
newest book you're talking about
institutions and these kind of things
and the respectful tradition and these
kind of things I'm not sure if I'm
reading you correctly but
these are the kinds of conversations I
think we need to have but on that point
I think I don't want this to be
well
the whole other half was like a whole
other different discussions upon Allah
but I think it's an important one
nonetheless I I I one point I actually
really wanted to mention was uh Jordan
patient seems to have this kind of
dilemma between
burning the sins of the people of the
past and fixing them but also you know
it's not fair to be burdened with the
sins of other people you know you
weren't even born yet why do you have to
kind of bear the sin so obviously we
don't bear the sin but that doesn't mean
we don't we don't bear responsibility
right I think it's safe to say it's fair
to say if you are in a position of power
that someone in previously that was in
that position of power misused it
misapplied it and caused corruption then
it's upon you as someone in that current
position of power because power is
responsibility obviously
um you know I'm not trying to be Ben
Parker but with great power comes great
responsibility at 100 you need to
fix whatever institutions were broken
when whatever was messed up I mean even
the example that Muhammad hijab gave of
the person basically like the the
Islamic ruler that was um unjust towards
Christians and Jews and all that stuff
did happen but when one basically
Islamic empire or Islamic ruler
was oppressive towards certain Jews and
there was actually like a a Jew who who
ran away and he was a governor of uh
basically under a Muslim Muslim rule he
basically ran from one Empire to another
Muslim empire and then wrote about how
good the Muslims were treating him there
uh so you know that's kind of what
Muslims have we have the responsibility
not the sin of another but we have the
responsibility to fix our societies
according to what Allah has taught us in
the Quran this touches on a point that
Jordan Peterson made earlier in that
video which is about uh the basically
unity and Islam that Islam is a basic
religion that calls people together and
brings Unity amongst people even the
most broken of society and he said
that's not exactly happening today and I
don't want to get too like you know
propositional Logic on people here but
we know that fulfilling Islam
um basically creates a
a a uniform Society right but that
doesn't mean if you don't have a uniform
Society then Islam failed it just means
you're the basically allegation or the
flipping that around means that you did
not I think is called the Contra
positive or something it means basically
you did not fulfill this step and if you
did fulfill Islam then you would have
the same kind of unity if you enter the
hearts of people and they actually want
to practice and implement it into the
state implement it into the world and
that's what we have to do as Muslims
um
I like the point that brother Muhammad
brought up about Colonial Amnesia bro I
like that term it's almost like they
forget about all the things that have
gone down and they like to just you know
project it onto you know the Muslims or
other races and ethnicities and
religions when they do the same thing
yeah 100 it is pure ethnocentrism it is
pure ethnocentrism you know you know
what the problem is bro what the problem
is Islam if it's unjustified you know it
like any of these Muslim empires or
Muslim nations doing these things that
are unjustified it's not backed by Islam
bro like Islam doesn't agree with this
Islam doesn't allow this but when you
look at all the things that are going on
the west what is it even based on bro
it's baseless it's not even like they
can say it's based on this or based on
that it's based on the whims and desires
of the people at that political time and
climate and the decisions that they make
to think that they're Justified
but It ultimately boils down to just
nothing bro hymns and desires
and 100 even the process suddenly he
said not just talking about our time
specifically about the years of
treachery and that stuff but also about
even soon after he passed away peace and
blessing to be upon him he spoke that
you're going to have basically like a
kingdom of of mercy and then a kingdom
of like of hardship and tyranny that's
what he were that's what he said tyranny
essentially so um yeah 100 and but if
you look at you know who our role models
are this is one of the the most kind of
or a lot of this basically expansion
happened with the Muslims
as well a lot of the expansion happened
with the Muslims and then you had people
essentially that went Australian and
cause like interfighting and that stuff
topic for another time insha Allah but
essentially the point here is that Islam
uh basically has a coherent way of life
a full system that is implemented in
people's hearts and on a societal level
will cause that Unity
it will cause that Unity that every
single place on the face of Earth lacks
today every single place on the face of
the Earth lacks it
um
agreed
I I think with that point if y'all do
not have anything else to add I think
this is a great point to
ended our phone
I agree bro nice and short
all right
30 minutes nice and short nice and short
brother for t3m Bros hello short I'm
there yeah yeah for real but I mean you
know comment down below what you guys
thought of this anything else you wanted
to react to Insha'Allah
um and trust me guys we're we're
definitely a work in progress we're
trying to figure this thing out too
ourselves we're gaining knowledge we're
seeking truth we're trying to you know
go to the people of knowledge and and
get our get our get our illum up you
know but you know at the end of the day
we're humans keep us in your Duos and uh
Mela got us all including Jordan
Peterson bro
um Dr Jordan Peterson for any weird
reason bro if you're watching us you
know
may Allah guide you and you know just
remember that you know the things that
Army was talking about with the
cognitive biases and the emotionality
these are real things and you don't need
us to remind you because obviously
you're a psychologist you know I'm like
us but these are these are the main
tenets of how we make decisions bro 99
if not all percent of our decision
making is through emotions so logic is
kind of just there as either a hindrance
or something that we must kind of
rationally get through before we go to
the emotion just like where the angel
said inshallah so may Allah allow us to
overcome these emotional issues which
are the real issues you know instead of
just logic Alone
um and allow us to what to you know
prioritize the emotion and reasoning
more than we do right now because right
now it's I see too many people including
ourselves at times it's very logical
no yeah 100 I mean and with that being
said